and tonight female athletes are now
taking a bold stand against biological
men that compete in women's sports one
female cyclist former Olympian
three-time Olympian is now calling on
her fellow competitors to boycott races
featuring trans women saying they should
take a knee at the starting line rather
than compete and former NC AAA swimmer
Riley Gaines is also calling on female
athletes to simply refuse to compete
against trans women as she says the
future of women's sports is at stake she
joins us now you know Riley all the
years I've been doing this I have
resisted any call for firing
cancellation boycotts
however in this particular case and
especially you've experienced it
firsthand I don't know what else would
work because there obviously is an
unfair competitive Advantage for someone
born a biological male to be competing
in women's sports because they identify
as a woman so I don't know any other
option in this case
uh tell me what you're thinking I don't
either
I don't know another option either this
past year I've been dedicated traveling
to state by state getting in front of
State Legislature same thing at the
federal level and I want to Echo what
Mark Levin said Biden does not care
about women we're seeing that with the
push they're they're proposing for Title
IX when the U.S House of Representatives
a few weeks ago voted on this and every
single Democrat voted in opposition of
protecting women and girls in sports
that's when I knew that a boycott is
what's going to have to be effective to
make change and we've seen in the past
boycotts are such they're effective it's
what's going to work and it's
unfortunate of course to ask girls to do
this but we have to start making
sacrifices if we want to protect the
Integrity of women's sports you know my
daughter's an athlete like you are and
the idea that biological men would that
become trans would be competing in her
sport it's imp it would be virtually
impossible
for any girl to compete on that level uh
and as Caitlyn Jenner said it's it's not
the testosterone level in college or in
the pros what was it at puberty that's
when it really matters and anything
prior to that as far as I'm concerned a
child would be way too young to make
such a life-changing decision would you
agree with that
absolutely and that's what we're seeing
the guidelines for Fina which is the
international governing body for
swimming and World Athletics which is
the equivalent for track and field
they've released new guidelines that say
if you have gone through male puberty
you cannot compete with the women but
the caveat there is if you've taken
hormone suppressors before the age of 12
I think is the standard level then you
are allowed to compete with women but
almost encouraging someone to transition
by that age is abysmal that's Criminal
I I nobody is mature enough to make that
decision and and the idea that you know
you have kids in school being taught
gender identity classes without parental
consent that's a whole separate issue to
me or having uh you know Story Hour uh
with this person or that person how
about Reading Writing math science
arithmetic and computers when you talk
to other athletes are they all
supporting you
female absolutely they are
um absolutely I have private
conversations all the time with NCAA
athletes very renowned world-class
athletes who when we have conversations
about this both male and female they all
unanimously agree with me athletic
directors coaches parents I get messages
all the time from people who feel the
exact same way I do but aren't confident
but a lot of them they're aren't they
afraid to speak out because they see
what has happened to you like when you
tried to give a speech in San Francisco
absolutely that social pressure on top
of seeing what happens to someone like
myself whether that be on social media
whether that be in San Francisco that
terrifies these people in an
understandably so they don't want to put
themselves in a position where they're
publicly ostracized or where they're
jeopardizing their chances to get into
grad school their job if they're The
Breadwinner for their family they're not
willing to do so but that's exactly how
we've gotten here and that's why I think
it's time we make sacrifices it's time
both female and male athletes honestly
need to start boycotting need to take a
knee need to not run not swim when that
starting block or when the gun goes off
don't go um 10 seconds left would you
support another category male athletes
female athletes trans athletes but
separate and apart
you know I think I don't know if it's
overly feasible I think in an Ideal
World this is something that everyone
could compete there would be equal
opportunity and all the things so in an
ideal world yes
Riley you've been very courageous we
appreciate you back on the show thanks
for being with us hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else